Bill bar and John
Bolton don't like Trump but they're
coming to his defense what are the
candidates doing in the 2024
presidential primary V ramaswami has
just pledged that if this decision is
not reversed he will pull his name off
the ballot in Colorado as well they have
just tried to Bar president Trump from
the Colorado ballot using an
unconstitutional maneuver that is a
bastardization of the 14th Amendment to
our US Constitution this was a provision
section three that was designed to bar
confeder members people switch to the
Confederacy from actually being able to
serve that's very different than what's
at issue here to say the least this is a
hollowed out husk of what the country
was built on the basic principle that we
the people select our leadership not the
unelected elite class in the back of
Palace Halls that's Old World Europe not
the United States that's why I'm making
a pledge today that I will withdraw I
pledge to withdraw from the Colorado GOP
primary ballot unless and until TR
Trump's name is
restored and I demand that Ronda sanis
and Chris Christie and Nikki Haley do
the same thing or else these Republicans
are simply complicit in this
unconstitutional attack on the way we
conduct our constitutional
republic very clever political maneuver
because it puts the other GOP candidates
on defense and I don't think this is
just a cynical Ploy I think it's an
admirable thing to do
I think that we cannot allow the
Democrats to decide who the GOP Nomine
is I think we cannot
allow elected and appointed officials in
the states who are big Libs to so
subvert our sacred democracy that we
hear so much about that they prevent
people from voting for the popular
candidate for
president I think it's it's admirable it
would send a strong message I've heard
some conservatives say that it would be
completely uh self-undermining for the
other GOP candidates to pull off the
ballot in the Colorado primary I don't
understand that I think it would be a
very strong statement of Republican
Unity to say first of all Colorado is
not going to choose the GOP nominee
Colorado primary is not for a very long
time it's not going to be decisive and
it sends a statement to say this is a
this is a bogus process this is a Banana
Republic kind of maneuver here and we
are not going to dignify it with our
president on the
ballots won't matter now a lot of the
candidates don't want to do that because
they want as many delegates as they can
possibly get to try to make some kind of
challenge to Trump which seems totally
implausible at this point Trump
continues to totally dominate the field
everywhere throughout the entire country
in every state so I it's not a huge cost
to the candidates other than it's an
acknowledgement that Trump is the
presumptive nominee a lot of them don't
want to to make that acknowledgement but
I think it would be a very strong
political maneuver for Republicans to do
do this to pull off of the ballot and to
say no we yes we're going to lose some
delegates I guess it's relatively low
cost because it's Colorado but more
importantly we're going to send a
message this election process is being
rigged by the Democrats this is a fake
election process you guys are are
rigging it in such a way that the
popular candidate will not be able to
Garner the votes of the people who want
to vote for him this is bogus we will
not go along with it and I think the rep
an who leave their names on the ballot
are going to be sending the opposite
message they're going to say well you
know too bad for you Trump hey Democrats
please let me stick around I'll be nice
right now go to jus.com letter y letter
T we all know Christmas can be hectic
the shopping the cooking the
never-ending list of things to do fear
not I have discovered a gift that is
both thoughtful and transformative the
gift of genu cell skincare from now
until Christmas janell's most popular
package has a special discount just for
our listeners jus.com
YT treat yourself and your loved ones to
the absolute best skincare in the world
those forehead wrinkles Fine Lines skin
redness and sagging jawline will
disappear right before your eyes with
genus cell's most popular collection
genus cell promises immediate effects
you'll see results in less than 12 hours
guaranteed or your money back you
deserve to look and feel your best this
Christmas season I love the founder of
this company Coptic Christian left Egypt
for the American dream their ingredients
are the absolute best in the business
the deal is incredible right now cuz
they know you're going to be a customer
for Life go to Jus cell.com letter y
letter T get this incredible Christmas
discount every order today instantly
upgraded to free express shipping
jus.com letter Y lettert today now Ronda
santis gives a good argument in the
opposite direction fellow GOP 2024
presidential candidate V ramaswami
saying he will remove himself from the
Colorado ballot unless Trump's
eligibility is restored would you do the
same no I think that just playing into
the left um I think the case will get
overturned by the Supreme Court but I've
qualified for all the ballots I'm
competing in all the states and I'm
going to accumulate the delegates
necessary that's the whole name of the
game in this situation but I do
anticipate that that decision was
political and will get reversed so that
last part there Dan santis is 100%
right if I were a Gambling Man which I'm
not but if I were a Gambling Man I would
put money on the Supreme Court
overruling this decision it's just
Preposterous it's a prepost
decision so what Des sandz is saying is
hold on I'm I'm not going to pull my
name off the ballot in Colorado and then
this decision gets reversed by the
Supreme Court and then Trump's on the
ballot and I'm not I'm not going to do
that that's crazy why would I ever do
that fair enough reasoning I think the
reasoning there is is
tight but Des Sis's stance looks bad
politically even the way he's saying it
looks bad he looks defensive he looks
irritated he looks peeved because no I'm
not come on no I'm not doing that I'm
going to be I've qualified for the
ballots I'm going to be on the ballots
no and it's going to get overturned
anyway it's not that big a deal come on
Move Along move along it doesn't look
good it it is a big deal even if it does
get overturned and I agree it probably
will be overturned it's a big deal that
the Democrats are using their political
power their their power in elected and
appointed office to totally subvert our
democracy which they purport to love so
much to prohibit people from voting on a
ballot for the popular candidate who
happens to be a former president who
happens to be the front runner in the
GOP field by a country mile that's a big
deal we haven't seen that ever actually
that they're going to reinterpret a post
Civil War provision of the Constitution
intended to stop Confederates from
taking over the government 150 years
later to stop the the mean orange man
from being on the ballot that's a big
deal okay and to to downplay that to
undermine it looks like you're fine with
this rigging it looks like you're fine
with this fraudulent electoral system
and
and this has been a problem with the
disantis campaign from day one which is
that the guy is super smart the guy's
super effective the guy is very
admirable in so many ways but he he just
doesn't seem to have the pizzazz on the
campaign Trail to to communicate that he
has what George will once referred to as
the Charisma of confidence of competence
he is he's very competent in office but
you also need the Charisma of Charisma
when you're on the trail and you also
need to be able to speak to broader
political movements and issues it's not
just nuts and bolts wonery it's not just
going in there and unclogging the pipes
if you're a plumber there there needs to
be a broader political Vision if you're
going to lead a broader political
movement and V is seizing on that right
now I'm not suggesting it's going to
boost his numbers above to santis or
anything like that but I just think V
understands the significance of that
moment and he has capitalized ing on it
much more than santis is even if his
reasoning on the court process and and
how the ballot is ultimately going to
look is totally sound man what a great
clip that was huh now whoa hold up ring
that Bell subscribe to the Michael NS
YouTube channel see you next time